good morning we have a break from the
routine
it's a weekend take it let's sing Our
Song what's our weekend song sing it
song that we just made up a new song
that's not this
that's not the song We Sing every time
it's the weekend
what's the actual song
okay sing the actual song We Sing every
time in the morning no it's not today is
the weekend
[Applause]
that's that's the actual song Hey
another thing I wanna I wanna show I
want to show the people baby I want to
show the people let me see those kicks
let me see those kicks your shoes your
shoes
look at these cool shoes little monkey
manga yeah
okay okay that's it all right dude okay
so Papa
had a really bright idea
because uh he's supposed to be dieting
still and every time I ask because I'm
not dieting I'm not moving into amassing
AKA bulk AKA get bigger because I want
to get more uh muscle muscle and not
bigger as in like an uncontrolled type
of bigger just I want to get I want to
do a clean yes
um
um so I'm not being as strict with my
diet as this guy in front of me should
be so since I'm not doing it I'm like
hey baby are you on a diet and then what
do you do
so it's been so like this next week
though because next week I'm getting
online for sure I'm dialed in I'm gonna
hit my steps this guy literally said
this two weeks in a row like this
12 weeks super strict no cheat meal 1900
calories a day then I have one week of
indulgence tying it up and it's the
third week of tightening it up but it's
the weekend so what's the song what's
the official song it's the weekend it's
the weekend no today is the weekend
weekend
today is the weekend we got two more
days of indulgence before I really
dilated
all right so yeah so because uh today is
the huh he had the idea to come to
griddle cakes because they have a
specific uh pancake that he's been
craving if you ever are in a very
chocolatey peanut buttery there's this
pancake called The Monkey Business only
available at good old cakes in Las Vegas
there's a couple of them wait is this
sponsored no I wish it was but sometimes
I'm in like a macadamia nut mood
sometimes I'm in like whatever mood you
know today I'm in a monkey business
pancakes
you want to punch me hey this is cool
Minecraft
lucky tell everyone which pancakes you
got oh yeah which one did you get
chocolate chocolate
he's playing Minecraft and he's fighting
we got lucky business too yeah of course
he did
of course
he's just gonna let that one yeah I
think we all heard it
oh my God look at that look at this
happy boy you're turning the Playboy I'm
looking at the love in your eyes this is
monkey look at you this you didn't even
look at taika like this when he was
first born yes I did don't you dare yes
I do look at that I had tears I had
tears in my eyes no you didn't ew what
is that coffee coffee you just put
coffee on your face oh my goodness look
here you go buddy let's go dude let's
make some space
and then this is the killer he said this
is the Banger right here thank you
the Razzle Dazzle baby white chocolate
raspberry this is Monkey Business this
is for the monkeys
why do you think Papa dancing right now
because he likes it oh smart boy
and I just got plain old steak and eggs
with my Razzle Dazzle honestly I thought
there was gonna be more whoa careful I
thought there was gonna be more
um fruit but we'll take it we'll take it
okay we are all done with breakfast and
now we're headed to where baby
and for what we are headed to the Thomas
and Max Center
at UNLV to watch the 2022 a d c c
championships okay you just spit all
over my hand but why is that that's so
crazy so 80cc for those of you guys that
don't know
it is the biggest grappling event of the
world and I say it's the biggest
grappling event because the best
wrestlers the best Jiu Jitsu
practitioners the best Judo guys like
all schools of wrestling grappling Jiu
Jitsu all those grappling Arts anything
besides getting punched in the face
comes together and it's the Olympics for
this sport so it's really cool to see
all kinds of people from like you know
different styles and stuff so for
example like one of my favorite
Grapplers is Nikki Rodriguez who you
guys seen
on our get close podcast he's competing
here today and you guys if you guys are
familiar with him he has he brings a
crazy wrestling style to jiu jitsu where
he's like slamming people on the ground
and stuff so it's really cool that it's
happening in our hometown because yes
Las Vegas is where I was born and raised
shut up so I'm really excited to see
like all of these guys like Face to Face
In the Flesh and hear them
no yeah so Bart was explaining to me
because this is a new realm for me
um he was explaining that it's the
Olympics because this originated in Abu
Dhabi
um and as the sport has grown and the
competition has grown it moves every
year to a different location so it is
rare
um that it comes to Las Vegas so it's
not going to be it wasn't here last year
and it's probably not going to be here
next year so it's really bad that it's
here this year so and I believe it
happens every two years so it's not even
every year okay so it's yeah it really
is kind of like the Olympics more of
like the Winter Olympics right because I
think the Winter Olympics every two
years anywho so I want something else I
want to add too so uh if you like MMA
this is why this matters okay okay cool
back in the day all the top MMA fighters
used to compete too GSP Matt Hughes Tito
Ortiz all those guys in the off season
they would compete to hone their
grappling skills at 80cc
but the caliber of 80cc has gotten so
high that the top MMA fighters would not
hang in here
it's how freaking crazy this is like
once you specialize and people have
taken their skill set to that next
Pinnacle those guys cannot hang so now
all of these guys that are here they're
at the Forefront of the sport so if you
guys are familiar with like the donor
her death squad GSP goes and pays pill
or takes a pilgrimage to go train with
John donoher and Gordon Ryan to uh bring
up his skills like that's the level that
grappling is at now
so that's why if you're into MMA or
Combat Sports in general that's why this
matters
back to you Geo cool I had no idea so
I'm glad you interjected there because I
got to learn a lot now I'm even more
hyped so I recently got into
um being a BJJ practitioner myself when
I swore up and down that I would never
do it because of my own limiting beliefs
of I don't like Combat Sports I I am
slightly claustrophobic so all of those
things
um I put aside and I'm like I really
want to do it so I started training at
the beginning of this year and I really
really enjoyed it unfortunately the
schedule just doesn't permit for me and
Papa to
um to continue but that I'm still a huge
fan of it so the fact that um now you
gave me all of this Insight I'm like
extra hella stoked and especially just
because we have friends there that are
competing that I'm like oh God I can't
wait to see them do and perform their
craft you know so I'm pretty stoked
back to you Bart just kidding
Papa wasn't lying we really were going
to the Thomas and Mac Center
I don't know you play too much so
we are at the international
cauliflower ear convention okay yeah
don't mess with anyone here though
they're gonna look at my ears this way
you don't do [ __ ] at any time so hey but
not everyone has to have cauliflowers
maybe you're maybe your hands could be
jacked up right here from grabbing all
the Gees no no they could tell about my
little little pretty hands out yeah you
don't do [ __ ] so I'll just I'll just
walk with my wallet all and then I can
take it whoever wants it
we are now inside
and the craziest thing just happened
randomly so we're waiting in the general
admission
line general admission line and that's
the longest line because it's just for
the general public
um and then randomly this really tall
man walks up to us he goes hey do you
guys want green uh green tickets which
means it's the next level up which means
you're closer to the stage because
General is like I guess nosebleeds
um and we're like wait what do we got to
do how much he goes no you and your kids
all three of you enjoy it I you know I
was expecting for my friends to come
they never showed up it's just me here
he goes here having the time we're like
no let's pay you he's like no and he
just randomly picked us from like a line
of like hundreds of people so Ken if
you're watching shout outs to you you're
freaking awesome but because of that
this guy can get so much closer wow he's
so excited so excited
okay we're going inside this is my first
time and it looks [ __ ] hype in there
oh
here we go whoa that looks so tight
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but thanks to that man we're down here
so close to the stage
because right down there is the black
section this is the green
[Applause]
here we go it's starting never seen this
before
what's even on the map
whoa
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
Las Vegas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so these are the first three matches all
happening at once look at this
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
those were some intense matches we left
halfway because we actually didn't plan
to stay there all day today it's a
two-day event
um I think it's more than two day event
honestly I think it's like a four or
five day event
um but today is like the semi-finals and
then tomorrow is the finals and like the
super fight so we just wanted to check
it out today and we didn't really bring
techos like we didn't we weren't too
prepared for Texas we got really really
bored so we're out of here and now this
is literally what we're gonna do
yeah this is a band named kiss I got to
play some other music but we're gonna
play some in uh indoor glow in the dark
kiss mini golf
we're gonna do it we're gonna play with
those guys
look at his cutie little shoes I like
them because they make his feet all
chunky and fat like when he was a little
toddler infant baby blue
he's too big now that's makeup
it's not tattoos it's makeup you know
that song uh wanna rock and roll all
night
a party every day we wait wait wait wait
wait no kicking you monster
oh my God
they don't kick
okay it's coming it's coming
oh my God
finally we are at
kiss World we're not big kiss fans but
the indoor glow in the dark
um uh golf stuff looked really cute so
let's go inside and check it out
so it's like this arcade
look at that
and then the golfing is over here
check that out
[Applause]
cute huh and we got
are you ready to rock
are you ready to rock
let's go hoodies let's go
oh yes kiss Crocs that's cool
oh god let's go hey come back come back
we have to go in order
[Applause]
yes you have to wait you have to wait
till people get out of here
Tyga's never done this before that's the
hole okay mister but you have to start
over here look come here over here
let's start here
watch Papa watch Papa go first
okay
okay
so that hole is over there right
exactly
[Music]
oh my God I thought you were gonna make
it okay ready wait wait can I teach you
okay go let's go
[Music]
that's it one time one time okay my turn
we only get one one hit
only one hit each okay mama here we go
how did you get in there I got skills
baby
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
both
[Applause]
Jacob
[Applause]
all right so we are all done and right
outside of
um the golf I normally notice Golf and
stuff they have records that kiss has
received check all that out they have a
hundred million sales worldwide but look
at all this
look at all this
freaking crazy
damn
and I still can't make this song
what's up monkey
you're gonna play a game
look at those hips look at those hips
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
so to close out our CUNY little day we
are at the park why are we at the park
taika
[Music]
you're gonna what
you're going to exercise he says we're
going to exercise but we're not gonna
exercise we're actually here so that he
could practice his skate some more
[Music]
what do it again
he's so fascinated with shaking his butt
and blowing kisses at me I don't know
what the fool
what this false deal is it's been an
eventful day we went from like not doing
much on the weekends just chilling to
like all this [ __ ] today holy crap am I
tired
but it's very kidney you must admit
they're playing hide and go seek
okay you found me so fast
so now Papa's trying to find taika
and he can't find Taiko for some reason
sure are you sure it's Tycho
[Applause]
ah here's him
hear those turquoise you sure they're
not yours
he got you
yeah
papa is definitely the fun parent
s
hey Papa can I ask you a question what
um
uh I got me
ah
because call it a do-over say do-over
Tyco say do over do over means you just
do it over
okay so nobody gets points but it's just
do-over am I the Tiger
[Applause]
we're back home now we didn't quite make
it
to the roller skating session because he
found a friend there or he made a friend
I should say
I played so hard that this is what
happened
he's worn the [ __ ]
got it
camera look at this guy
he's about cold he's not even his
bedtime yet but he's
he's out
so I'm not help friends we are out too
thank you so much hope you're having a
beautiful day if not I hope this Vlog
brought a little small to your face
thank you so much love you see you